what about this idea that's family
before everything else so like you're
you know there's there's different laws
you live up
according to in this world and family is
first yeah
that's that's that's mathematically
correct
i don't like that
i mean there's uh there's a certain
sense of um
you look at powerful people you look at
putin
there's a certain sense in which the
people who are in the inner circle
that's who you take care of that's
family anyone else that crosses you
that you know there's a different set of
ethics under which you operate for those
people
well
jesus said the same thing
you know when he said love thy neighbor
and our brother he was talking about
that community yeah
when that other lady the samaritan
say hey jesus i'm not feeling my brother
not feeling so well and because he said
give not that which is holy unto the
dogs
if you're gonna tell a woman
i'm give not that which is holy
unto the dogs and she's a woman you just
called her a dog
if i translate that in hip-hop
yeah female you call the dog
i know how that goes but she tried but
she said to him
but even the dog is allowed to eat the
crumbs that falls from the masters table
and he went helped
he helped now let's go back to what you
said about putin or vito colon or myself
and my family
of course the family is first
but once the family is good
it has to then spread to the community
then to the
state
country world
the problem we have sometimes is that
and this is the reason why a lot of
powerful families was overthrown like
why did they be had their own
king with the guillotine right because
that once the family was strong
they didn't let the
the wealth
the opportunity
expand out
you know you look at wu-tang
yes our family was made strong first but
then
all the women was able to form their own
corporations and they had their own
sub-families
it has to grow out and they took over
the world
you